after an extraordinarily contentious
first debate between trump and biden
democrats float canceling further
debates and the media pressed forward at
the accusation that trump is soft on
white supremacy i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn surf the web with peace of
mind sign up now at expressvpn.com
slash ben in one second we'll get to
everything newsy but first
let me remind you um it's a little bit
uncertain out there have you noticed
there's a big election coming
up and kovid's still out there and who
knows whether there can be more
lockdowns who knows whether the stock
market is going to go up or down
will but will biden pack the supreme
court if he's made president will trump
win and then everybody will go crazy and
burn the cities
uncertainty means that you might want to
diversify your finances
just a little bit and one of the ways
that you do this is to make sure that
you're a little beast a little bit
at least a little bit into precious
metals this is why i trust the folks
over
at birch gold just like i keep telling
you to do wouldn't it be nice to have a
layer of security whichever way the wind
blows text ben 247-4747
one of the great people at birch gold
will then walk you through your
conversion of your eligible ira or 401k
into a precious metals ira where the
physical metal the not etfs will be
stored securely
birch gold they're my folks they have an
a plus rating with the better business
bureau countless five star views talk to
them
they're extremely knowledgeable they can
help you preserve your savings again you
should diversify at least a little bit
into precious metals if you had listened
when i told you to do this the first
time you'd be much
but much better off financially than you
are right now so listen this time
and then three years from now you'll
look back and think hmm that was a smart
decision
text ben to 47 4747 open a precious
metals ira today again
text ben to 47 47 47
alrighty so we are still in the midst of
the fallout from that
extraordinarily contentious rough
brutal to watch debate between trump and
biden where basically
trump yelled over biden for about an
hour and a half
and then biden said really snarky and
terrible things punctuated by outright
lies and then chris wallace tried to
intervene
and himself became the subject of the
debate it was really
awful like all the way around and it was
not productive from
any possible angle one of the things
that happened is the medium went nuts i
mean
how could this have happened how could
we have reached this point in american
life's disgrace to the american system
it's such a disgrace and i mean
i thought that the debate was not good i
mean i talked about it at length
yesterday i talked about it the night of
the debate on daily wire backstage i
thought this
was a very very bad debate because the
purpose of a debate is to inform you
about the people who are participating
basically just reinforce what you
already knew
maybe provide you a little new
information maybe put the positions of
the participants
in a different light and the debate
really didn't get into policy very much
or if it did it was completely obscured
by the bizarre antics that were evident
from every available side
but when the media complains about this
being the low point of our democracy i
mean people like john meacham the
historian saying this was the low point
of the presidency in the united states
and people on cnn complaining that this
was
it was unprecedentedly bad all i could
think was
you are dr frankenstein and this is your
monster
i've been saying for a long time and one
of the great misconceptions about trump
is that trump is the murderer of
american politics there's this weird
thing that has happened in american
politics
ever since trump became president where
everybody assumes that every bad thing
began with trump and the reality of
course is that donald trump is not the
murderer he is the coroner this is the
this is the metaphor that i have been
using for at least several years here
donald trump stumbled upon the body of
american politics
it was all it was warm i mean it was
warm had been recently murdered
but the fact is that he was not the guy
who originally stuck the knife in now
was he a doctor did he fix the body
politic no of course he did not he
proceeded to stand over the body and
watch it bleed out but
was donald trump the guy who originally
brought us to this point
no in fact he was not and i have proved
positive of this
so last night on cnn ted cruz senator
ted cruz who
all all facts disclosed i'm very
friendly with senator cruz of course
senator cruz was on with chris cuomo
block of wood
on cnn now chris cuomo's not a reporter
chris cuomo is a political activist
masquerading as a reporter
most evident when he was doing these
bizarre interviews
with his brother andrew cuomo who is
busily presiding over the
worst regime in the united states with
regard to handling of covet
shipping elderly people back into
nursing homes with covet
ensuring that the state then covered up
those numbers by pretending that if you
died outside of a nursing home
even if you acquired coveted in a
nursing home that was not listed as a
nursing home death refusing to answer
foia requests
openly denying this week that he'd ever
done that which was pretty incredible
and then saying that every night when he
puts his head down on his pillow he
knows that he has saved lives i mean
andrew cuomo's behavior during this
entire debacle has been
devastatingly bad and chris cuomo's been
covering for him the entire way
so this was a meeting between two
partisan actors
one is openly partisan senator cruz is
perhaps the most partisan republican
in congress right this is perfectly
obvious this has been true for years
it's not like he's hiding the ball here
senator cruz is not a quote unquote
objective reporter
chris cuomo however is a quote unquote
and chris cuomo spent about 20 minutes
berating cruise last night on cnn about
20 minutes
now the reason this is relevant is
because the media created this
environment
and then they are very upset to learn
that this is now the environment in
which we live
so a lot of this in the aftermath of
debate with regard to 2012 i saw people
tweeting out about
remember that quaint old time when
people attacked mitt romney for his
binders full of women
and people treating that like oh it's a
quainter time no the story there is that
you guys did go after
mitt romney for the binders full of
women comment which was the most
innocuous comment in the history of
presidential debate
he literally said i tried to recruit
women into my administration when i was
governor of massachusetts
and i had a binder filled with the
resumes of women so that i could pick
women who are qualified for positions
and they treated that as though it was a
sexist thing to have a binder
filled with the resumes of females okay
it was your fault
that you got trump it was your fault we
got the debate last night
you brought us to this point and the the
complete lack
of self acknowledgement the complete
lack
of mirror ownership apparently at cnn
leads the same people who engage
in this sort of nonsensical talking over
each other screaming at people treating
people like garbage on national tv
day in and day out then turn around and
they're like
how could trump do this sort of thing
he's one of you the answer is he's one
of you donald trump was a media creation
donald trump is a member of the media
people like to say that trump hates me
trump does not hate the media there is
nobody in american politics who loves
the media more than donald trump he
obsesses with the media he talks with
the media i mean if he hated the media
so much why would he let bob woodward in
the front door and do 18
hours of interviews with him donald
trump loves the media he's obsessed with
the media and the media
are obsessed with donald trump so much
so that there is a story in the new york
times today i mean this just
demonstrates
the bizarre the insane loop that has
been created between trump and the media
there's a story in the new york times
today talking about how trump is the
single greatest source of misinformation
in politics today anywhere on the globe
how did they measure that they looked at
the number of headlines
including trump and misinformation so in
other words because trump says something
and the media are obsessed with him and
print one thousand headlines about the
thing he said
that means that he is the source of
misinformation the chief source of
misinformation
or alternatively you guys are the
loudspeaker you guys are the ones who
decide where to shine the spotlight
you're the ones who have decided to
turn every issue in american politics
into a crisis issue
in american politics so back to this
chris cuomo and ted cruz interview
i want you to see if you can distinguish
the behavior of chris cuomo here from
the behavior of donald trump in that
debate the other night
you're gonna find it it's very hard to
do it's very hard to do
the the level of the debate in which we
engage in politics in this country is
the stupidest possible level which by
the way is why people now go to podcasts
it's why the ratings on cnn overall have
declined they've increased relative to
their ratings over the past few years
but just overall in terms of general
audience share there's a reason that
fewer people
are now watching things like chris cuomo
and more people are watching long-form
podcasts especially
long-form podcasts like for example joe
rogan where he will do three-hour
interviews with people with whom he
disagrees
and explicate their viewpoints they
watch podcasts like this one they watch
podcasts like my sunday special where i
will have on matthew iglesias from vox
and we'll just discuss ideas for a full
hour
because guess what this stuff is getting
old it really is getting old and the
media
created it members of the media act like
this and the left cheers they love it
when chris cuomo acts like a jackass
to ted cruz when he talks over him when
he insults him when he brings up ted
cruz's wife
and suggests suggested ted cruz is a
coward for not attacking donald trump
more
meanwhile defending his own brother the
members of the media they dig this this
is the thing man
the left is into it they love it every
second and they're like well donald
trump does that it's so bad it's so
because you built this machine guys you
built the machine
we can have a very reasonable policy
discussion about the policy mistakes in
new york and new jersey
of sending covid positive patients into
nursing homes i think that was
happening all over the country
one of the reasons why you're the death
rate in new york is four times the death
rate texas the place where the governor
said that you didn't need to test and
you didn't need masks right
that guy is that what you're talking
about was it was it
a mistake when your brother implemented
a policy that nursing homes
had to accept covet positive patients
and endangered the lives of my brother
was the first one to say
but there was a learning curve and that
mistakes were made and they changed
things as soon as they could
okay everybody turns up the heat here
okay again it gets even worse than this
chris cuomo starts
openly defending his brother's behavior
and then brings up ted cruz as though
it's ted cruz's job
to condemn donald trump in the same way
that it's chris cuomo's job to be an
objective journalist
the journalists and the politicians you
see are exactly the same the journalists
and the politicians
are are to be treated exactly the same
the only difference is you're supposed
to pretend the journalists are
journalists
here's chris cuomo continuing this my
brother will stand for his own republic
why don't you talk to the president the
way you talk to my brother ted you're
afraid of him do you think he'll smack
you down at home
is that what it is like he's terrified
you you guys are really
i'm talking about the president my
brother's not the president i'm talking
about the president the one who called
you a liar
you're perfectly fine to scream and yell
because you know what but you don't
you're doing it because you don't want
to discuss the substance like i had you
you invited me on the show to actually
talk about the supreme court and talk
about the book one vote away
and instead you just want to repeat
insults over and over
and over again well you're not actually
talking about you just bring up my
brother for half the interview because
you're such a fair guy
okay this is incredible bringing up his
his brother is the governor of new york
and you're talking about covet policy it
seems a little relevant to bring up the
fact that your brother the governor of
new york
who was treated with kid gloves by you
on national tv
for weeks at a time that that was a
failure of coverage on your part that is
not the same thing
as ted cruz doing the partisan thing and
defending trump he's a republican
senator from texas what the hell do you
think he's going to do
he doesn't have the same job as chris
cuomo the generalized point here is this
well you hear everybody in the media
complaining about donald trump
you guys created this toxic brew and
then you're like oh this is toxic brew
this is really bad i can't believe it's
so bad as all this i can't believe that
it's really really bad
jeff zucker was calling the trump
campaign in the middle of the trump
campaign to give advice to michael cohen
you can't you can't do this you can't do
this it's not that
you can certainly criticize trump for
his behavior you can certainly criticize
anybody you want
but you might want to check whether the
house that you're living in is literally
made of glass before you start chucking
those sorts of stone okay so how were
the actual ratings from the debate
not particularly good they actually
nosedived from 2016 which suggests as i
thought before that there are very few
people who have not made up their mind
in this election cycle which given the
polling data right now is very bad for
trump and very bad for republicans
across the country
cook political recently re-raided iowa
from leans republican
to to deadlock basically to turn
to um to throw up it's a it's a it's a
it's an even state now they now moved
ohio in the same way it was a lean
republican state and now they've landed
into a toss-up it's a toss-up state
so the polls are trending away from
trump in a lot of these places
people have made up their minds it seems
and unless something dramatic changes
it's going to be a rough night for trump
if you if you look at the polls now
again
maybe the polls are all skewed maybe it
turns out that that trump still
he has a 30 shot at winning the
presidency that doesn't mean he has a
zero percent a shot it means you know
one in four times you run this
simulation
trump wins the presidency but right now
he's got a deficit to make up that
debate
definitely did not do it for him the
ratings on the debate were abysmal
the chaotic first presidential debate
according to the new york post between
joe biden and president trump officially
tanked
pulling in dismal tv ratings compared to
the blockbuster showdown between trump
and hillary clinton
four years ago networks abc nbc cbs and
fox averaged 27.3 million viewers during
the 90 minute plus
slugfest according to deadline that is a
plunge from the face-to-face brawl
between then candidate donald trump and
hillary clinton
in 2016. again that was very much
because
nobody really was tuning in to see biden
get clocked per se
nobody hates biden the same way that so
many people
despised hillary clinton and so there
wasn't that sort of tension and build up
to this particular debate nonetheless
the commission
on presidential debate now says that
they are going to redo the format
of these debates they have decided that
the
debates themselves are not orderly
enough because trump talked over
biden for a lot of the debate and so now
they are probably going to give the
ability
for the moderator to mute the mics which
of course has created its own set
of controversies now do i think that's a
good idea
honestly i think that it's not a bad
idea i do i mean
the fact is that during the lincoln
douglas debates which we're pretty
famous debates people talk for like half
an hour
and the other guy talked for half an
hour then they would have 10-minute
rebuttals and then they would do it one
more time and that would be the whole
debate
that that seems like a better way of
doing it than than what we saw the other
night so i don't object to the idea of
changing the rules
i just object to the idea that changing
the rules
after they've already been set is a good
idea but at the same time i think it's
kind of fair i mean
i do trump is the one who broke the
rules from the beginning so
making clear that he can't just set the
rules and then ignore the rules i don't
think that that's necessarily a bad
thing but i think that they should get
rid of a lot of the rules that they
stand right now i don't think you can
say a lot that's illuminating inside of
two minutes
instead of trying to get through 35
topics how about we have like two topics
and everybody has to speak at length and
then we get to watch these guys
jabber for half an hour and by the way
that'd be the best for trump right
we know that trump can go off the cuff
for half an hour can joe biden go off
the cuff for half an hour right now
i have serious doubts that i should
benefit trump if they went toward that
format
we'll get to more of this in just one
second more of the
debate fallout because democrats of
course have decided that the pure story
from the debate is donald trump's white
supremacy again based on an exchange
in which he literally said that he was
willing to connect white supremacy twice
it's amazing i pointed this out
yesterday and people on the left went
nuts
idiot seth rogen on twitter came after
me suggesting that i was selling out to
white supremacy
if seth rogen had received 1 100th of
the hate from white supremacists that i
have received from white supremacists
he would shut the hell up because the
fact is there is no one in america
who has been harder on white
supremacists than i have nor is there
anybody
literally by statistics in 2016 i was
the number one target of the alt-right
and white supremacist according to the
anti-defamation league
so the suggestion that if i correctly
characterize trump's comments the other
night
that that is some sort of sellout to
white supremacism that is because you
guys are so full of crap that your eyes
are turning brown
we'll get to more of that in just one
moment first let us talk about the fact
that you need to constantly
make your employees better you do now
let's say that there's this wonderful
new employee let's call her savvy for
example and
let's say that savvy is just she's
terrific at her job like great in every
way but
when she first entered your office she
informed you
that while she had gotten your book your
brand new book how to destroy america in
three easy steps she had not completed
it
let's say she had said that wouldn't
your first instinct to be
well you know savvy should have done
your homework and then immediately head
over to zip recruiter
well i won't say that we did actually
relist her job on zip recruiter let's
just say
that she is now on an interim an interim
trial period
because that's how this works around
here we have high standards you should
have high standards too and that's why
you should use
ziprecruiter zip recruiter sends your
job to over 100 of the web's leading
job sites but they don't stop there with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and then actively invites them
to apply to your job zip recruiter makes
hiring efficient and effective with
features like screening questions to
filter candidates and an all-in-one
dashboard where you can review and rate
your candidate
ziprecruiter in fact is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within
the very first day right now to try zip
recruiter for free my listeners can go
to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-re
slash daily wire zipper crew is indeed
the smartest way to hire
okay so fallout from the debate so chris
wallace said that he never dreamed that
the debate would go off the rails
that way he told this to the new york
times he said i've read some of the
reviews i know people think well gee i
didn't jump in soon enough
i guess i didn't realize there's no way
you could hindsight being 2020 this was
going to be the president's strategy
not just for the beginning of the debate
but for the entire debate
he said i'm a pro i've never been
through anything like this and it's true
that trump's tactics definitely threw
wallace
off his game and that is certainly true
again i don't think that trump's
behavior in that debate
helped him very much but does that mean
that wallace did a great job anywhere
throughout
no no it doesn't okay trump for his part
said he was disappointed in chris
wallace and that he was also
disappointed in fox news
i got to say this sort of stuff gets old
you are the president of the united
states how you behaving debate is on you
here was trump yesterday in duluth
did you see last night name one
i said sleepy joe name one
law enforcement group that supports you
and then chris wallace says
don't do that that's not can you believe
this guy i was debating two people last
night can you go to church
no can you go to restaurants no can you
do anything no but you can riot that's
okay
arson's okay but challenging sleepy joe
is totally off limits
uh so disappointed in fox okay so i
think that some of his critiques of
wallace are fair i also think that some
of wallace's critiques of trump are fair
bottom line is
that that debate really didn't
accomplish much other than it gave
democrats a talking point for the next
couple of weeks a talking point that by
the way
happens to be not true so for their part
democrats of course
got very offended right joe biden said
the debate was a national embarrassment
and it was it was a national
embarrassment it says joe biden
who literally in 2012 said that mitt
romney is going to put black people back
in chains joe biden says this was a
national embarrassment for 90 minutes
he tried everything to distract
everything possible
and it just uh it just didn't work
the president united states
conducted himself the way he did um
i think was just a national
embarrassment
okay and then chuck schumer put out the
suggestion and you're starting to see
this
increase in in sort of volume chuck
schumer the senate minority leader he
said i don't think that trump should
want to debate biden against they're
putting out the message now that maybe
the rest of the debates should be
canceled
remember biden's entire strategy here is
to run out the clock
that's why what trump did the other
night was really not good for him
because he should have let biden talk
the whole point here is that biden
cannot talk and when he does he makes
big boo-boos
that was a strategic blunder by trump
but democrats basically want to take the
ball and go home now here's chuck
schumer
unless he's trying to lose i don't think
donald trump should want to debate joe
biden again
second i would say maybe we should give
the moderator a mute button
given how president trump just
interrupts it will
and the bottom line is donald trump
doesn't follow the rules
the commission's got to get a lot
tougher
when debate participants don't follow
the rules
all righty so they they're already
talking about the possibility of
shutting down future debates so joe
biden can go back into the basement and
run out
the clock which again underscores the
entire strategy here is to make it about
trump and you saw this in the debate
this is where wallace really failed he
should have held biden's feet to the
fire on the very simple question as to
whether he's going to pack the supreme
court which by the way is the single
most transformative question up in this
election
if you are taking one of the three
branches of government and rendering it
absolutely obsolete in terms of its
legitimacy to the american
public by packing it with a bunch of
partisans
then that seems like that might be
worthy of discussion and joe biden
should not have been able to get away
with
go out and vote that's not how any of
that works
okay well all of this takes a backseat
to the generalized
the generalized narrative that the media
have attempted to draw from the debate
and that is once again as always
that donald trump is a white supremacist
now just to recap
okay donald trump is not a white
supremacist
donald trump's history with condemning
white supremacy
is pretty long meaning that it was
insert let's put it this way it was
intermittent
for a long time there are a couple of
instances in which he did not and in
which i duly ripped the living crap out
of him
you'll recall back in 2015 when he did
an interview with jake tapper and jake
tapper asked him to denounce david duke
and he said i don't know who david duke
is and then he refused to announce him
and you'll remember i just ripped into
him i savaged him over this
it was right before the louisiana
primary it was really really ugly and
then you'll remember in charlottesville
where he actually
did condemn white supremacists but he
said there were good people who were
marching with the white supremacist
which happened not to be true and that
was
shortly after he had said that some very
bad things happened
in charlottesville and he sort of
ignored the ideological component then
he came back and he revised and then he
recognized the ideological component
okay
ever since then i mean he's given
multiple speeches in which he has talked
about the evils of white supremacy he
has repeatedly condemned white supremacy
trump has not been shy over the last
several years in condemning white
supremacy
in fact you remember in 2017 even during
the charlottesville mess where he was
completely inept
he said that white supremacy should be
totally condemned this was in 2017.
you had people and i'm not talking about
the neo-nazis and the white nationalists
because they should be condemned totally
but you had many people in that group
other than neo-nazis and white
nationalists okay
and the press has treated them
absolutely unfairly
okay so the problem with that comment
was the people other than the neo-nazis
and the white supremacists didn't exist
but he says i'm not talking about the
neo-nazis and the white supremacist and
in fact
you can compile a list of all the times
his condemning nazis and white
supremacists he's done it many many
many times but because the media ran out
of the russian narrative they decided
immediately to shift over to the racism
narrative
it's not as though this was not planned
it was absolutely planned
dean baquet of the new york times
literally said in print
right after the russia narrative
collapsed right after the mueller report
they said we are shifting over our
reporters to the racism beat
they put out a full article talking
about this how they were re-staffing up
to cover racism in the lead-up to the
2020 election this is a pre-set
narrative
and wallace walked right into the preset
narrative and trump
because he is inept with human language
beta made a boo-boo but it was not a
boo-boo in which he was saying white
supremacy is okay
you cannot read the comments that he
said and come away with white supremacy
is okay unless you wish to have that
conclusion
going in he'll get to that in just one
second because that is the conclusion
the media are drawing of course we'll
get to that
first let us talk about the fact you are
paying way too much for your cell phone
bills i'm going to be very direct with
you right now if you're selling your
planet with verizon att t-mobile you're
simply paying way too much for the exact
same coverage you would be getting right
now with puretalk
look at that cell phone bill where it
shows data usage the average person who
switches to pure talk
is using less than four gigs of data a
month but the big carriers are charging
you for unlimited data
it's like paying for an entire row on an
airplane but you only need one seat why
would you do that
that's how pure talk saves the average
person over 400 a year on their wireless
service
unlimited talk text two gigs data all
for just 20 bucks a month why would you
be
spending a fortune on unlimited data
that you are not using you're not using
unlimited data
folks switching over to talk it's the
easiest decision you will make
today so grab that mobile phone dial
pound 250 say ben shapiro when you do
you say 50
off your first month so i'll pound 250
say keyword ben shapiro
puretalk it's simply smarter wireless go
check them out right now dial pound 250
say ben shapiro and when you do you save
off your first month of coverage again
so i'll pound it two five zero
say keyword ben shapiro to get involved
with my friends over at puretalk and
lower
that cell phone bill by like half it's
gonna be good for you go check it out
pound 250 say ben shapiro okay so again
the narrative that is now coming out
from the left
and it's gonna they're gonna try and run
this all the way to the election is that
trump is soft again on white supremacy
now do i think that's gonna shift votes
no i think we've done this routine
several times before
it seems like it comes up every several
months so joy behar
is uh the the most blunt instrument in
the democratic arsenal so here she was
yesterday on the view suggesting that
trump himself was a white supremacist
yes i'm sure that's right i'm sure that
donald trump the guy who signed into law
criminal justice reform
who moved the embassy in israel to
jerusalem
whose daughter is jewish and his
grandchildren are jewish
and who has evinced tremendous love for
both jews and black americans
and there's a guy going back decades who
was hanging out with like don king
here's joy behar talking about how
donald trump is not just soft on white
supremacy again he's made comments in
the past where i think he was
did he do that the other night no he did
not she doesn't just say he was soft on
white supremacy she goes
ho hog because that's joy behar she
she's never met
anything like a moderate statement she
says instead donald trump is himself a
white supremacist
can i just say one thing so of course he
doesn't denounce
white supremacy sonny because he is a
white supremacist
americans have to decide whether they
want a white supremacist
in the white house we've never had it
before maybe we didn't know we had it
but we
certainly know we have it now okay no
no no no okay so here is here's the
white supremacist yesterday so the white
supremacist in chief yesterday
here he was he was asked specifically
about denouncing white supremacy
here was his answer they should stop
defunding the police like they've done
in new york
like they've done in new york i just
told you
i've always denounced any form any form
any form of any of that you have to
denounce
but i also and joe biden has to say
something about
antifa it's not a philosophy these are
people that hit people over the head
with baseball bats
he's got to come out and he's got to be
strong and he's got to condemn
antifa and it's very important that he
does it okay so first of all
he's right he's absolutely right here
that the media have completely ignored
the fact that during that debate joe
biden refused to condemn an actual
violent group antifa who've been
committing acts of
heinous violence and up to including
murder in america's major cities and
that's going completely by the wayside
like he openly did that okay you didn't
have to read into the comments to get
there joe biden literally refused to
condemn antifa from a presidential stage
and no one gives a damn in the media
that's an actual violent group the vast
majority of the violence happening in
our cities right now the city is burning
that is not white supremacist it is not
white supremacists in chicago
and la and new york and dc it's not
white supremacists in portland
it's not white supremacists in seattle
there's a bunch of left-wing groups
joe biden has been able to get away with
that because the media are so
militarized against trump that they
seriously do not care if joe biden
decides to make excuses for antifa
and chris cuomo was a big antifa
defender in the early days
he still occasionally will kind of let
that mask slip a little bit
so he's right back but the key quote
there is of course i defend this i
uh of course i denounce white supremacy
i denounce all forms of this i've always
denounced
all forms of this okay so let's just
replay
for the sake of people's ears and eyes
who are you gonna believe
seth rogen enjoy behar and the members
of the new york times editorial board or
your own ears so i'm going to replay
the exchange that happened from the
debate the other night and see if you
can find in here
donald trump not denouncing white
supremacy seriously
there's there's only one way that you
can get there and i'll explain in a
second
but you have to have the preconceived
notion going in that trump is a white
supremacist in order to come away with
that conclusion
okay let's play the clip are you willing
tonight
to condemn white supremacists and
militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland okay are
you prepared
there for a second he has now said in
the first 10 seconds of this clip
sure twice sure and then he says again
sure i'm willing to do that and then
trump
turns right he turns and he swivels and
he says i don't understand why we're
talking about right right-wing violence
in cities that are being dominated by
left-wing violence i don't understand
this why aren't we talking about blm why
aren't we talking about antifa that is a
perfectly legitimate point
okay and then wallace because he was
terrible the other night decides that
he's gonna double down on this
yes sir but will you conde he already
did twice he said sure
two times if he wanted to say no he
would just shake his head or he would
say no you think donald trump
is is unwilling to say things that piss
people off he does it all the time
okay but the fact is that he does
condemn white supremacy he does
condemn these people who are committing
violence in the cities if they are from
the right
okay like i'm sorry but okay so there's
only
there's literally a three-word thing
that trump says in the rest of this
exchange
that everybody on the left is hanging
their hat on to claim that he is in fact
a white supremacist okay and the only
way you can read this is if you think
that trump is exact with his language
which we all know he is not
it is amazing how the left which fully
understands that donald trump is wildly
in exact with his language that donald
trump routinely says dumb crap
how suddenly they get super serious and
meticulous about his literal language
all the time now listen i understand the
left saying to people on the right you
know you guys you say that you should
take him seriously not literally and
that
that lets him out of the that lets him
basically say whatever he wants to say
and we're supposed to read into his
words but i don't even take him
seriously i've said this all along
i've been very consistent about this i
don't think that virtually anything
trump says ought to be taken seriously
because i don't think that he's the
world's most serious person
i don't think it's possible to look at
trump and think he's the world's most
serious person i think very often
there's a core of truth to things that
he says
but i do not think that he is exact in
his language i don't think that he
thinks out what he's doing beforehand it
doesn't okay so here is the rest of the
exchange
do it say i would say almost everything
i see
is from the left wing not from the right
what are you what are you
what are you saying i'm willing to do
anything i want to see peace
sir say it do it say it do you want to
call him
what do you want to call him give me a
name give me a white surprise
stand back and stand by but i'll tell
you what
i'll tell you what somebody's got to do
something about antifa and the left
because this is not a right-wing problem
this is okay so stop it there so
he already said right at the top sure
twice i'm willing to condemn white
supremacy
and then the thing stops dead right for
the first time the entire debate it
stops dead
because he literally is confused you can
see he's confused they're saying to him
both biden and wallace then do it sir do
it he's like i don't know what you want
me to do i literally just said that i
condemn
the white supremacists and i condemn the
violence in the cities who are we
talking about like i don't know who
we're talking about and the reason he
says i don't know who we're talking
about
is because the left lumps every single
human being together the left pretends
that everybody they disagree with is a
white supremacist
okay this is unfortunately a common
left-wing trope is that everyone they
disagree with is a white supremacist let
me give you a perfect example so
yesterday joe biden releases an
ad okay this ad is about donald trump
not apparently fighting back against the
white supremacists hard enough
you'll see even in the chris wallace
question there he says white
supremacists in right-wing militia
groups
okay so number one you can condem
anybody who's getting involved in
violence that is illegal
that's fine but if you are going to say
that all of these quote unquote
right-wing militia groups are the same
ideologically as white supremacists that
is inaccurate
right but the the left likes to do that
ideologically they are not the same
the left has now grouped together for
example patriot prayer which is a not
racist
group with actual white supremacists who
are in fact racist
joe biden did an ad yesterday where he
grouped together he in order to
in order to group together everybody who
they disagree with they grouped together
kyle rittenhouse
and and white supremacists who were
marching that unite the right garbage
people rally
okay kyle rittenhouse for all the idiocy
of going
to a riot site with a gun okay
he shouldn't have done it i've said that
a thousand times he's not a white
supremacist there's no evidence he's a
white supremacist joe biden groups them
together with the white supremacists in
this ad
so here is that ad from from joe biden
yesterday
are you willing tonight to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared to specifically
do it i don't say i would say almost
everything i see
is from the left wing not from the right
what are you what do you
what are you saying i'm willing to do
anything i want to see peace and do it
sir say it
do it say it do you want to call him
what do you want to call him give me a
name give me a white surprise
stand back and stand by
okay and then okay so here's here's
where they are here's what they are
they're relying on they're relying on
those three words and stand by
okay so what was trump saying when he
said and stand by do you really think
that he was saying stand back and then i
want you to stand by is like a
paramilitary organization
or do you think that what he meant was
stand back and stand down
okay which one do you think that he
meant i can tell you what gavin mcginnis
the founder of the proud boy said
he literally was he was doing an online
follow of this particular
debate and in the middle he said wait a
second he just told us to stand back and
stand down i'm the head of the proud
boys donald trump isn't the head of the
brown boys so gavin guinness the head of
the proud boys understood that what
trump was saying was stand down
but donald trump isn't the head of the
prophecies okay beyond that
notice the attempt by the left to again
lump everybody in
under one rubric now i'm not a proud
boys guy i don't like the proud boys
i've told them before i don't want them
involved with anything
that i do right they've offered in the
past some of the proud boys to go to
like speeches that i give and provide
secure i'm like what the hell you guys
are a paramilitary group i don't want
anything
to do with the proud boys but to lump
them in as white supremacists right that
is the next step so in order to get to
trump didn't condemn white supremacy you
have to make a logical leap here
the logical leap is that the proud boys
number one are white supremacists and
number two
trump was attempting to embolden them
rather than telling them to stand down
okay those are two logical leaps neither
of which is inevitable
number one he told them to stand back
when he said stand by do you think he
meant stand back and i want you to stand
by
in paramilitary fashion i suppose you
could interpret it that way if that's
how you want to
but i don't think that's what he was
saying and i think it's fairly obvious
that he meant stand back and stand down
okay beyond that in order to get to this
point you have to lump together
white okay so he says twice in that
exchange will you condemn white
supremacy
sure okay and then he says who are you
talking about specifically and joe biden
jumps in and gives the name proud boys
hey now
in order to get to trump is soft on
white supremacy you then have to say
that the proud boys are white
supremacist group
in fact as cnn reported yesterday they
are not a white supremacist group
they may be a paramilitary organization
they may be an organization
whose members engage in illegal activity
some of whose members have engaged in
white supremacy but as an organization
they actually condemn white supremacy as
cnn's own reporters acknowledged
yesterday
we should be really clear that the proud
boys do not consider themselves a white
supremacist group they have
members from many different ethnicities
uh that doesn't mean that they have not
wreaked havoc and they're more like a
political fight club if you will
um than a white supremacist group and
have distanced themselves so in order to
get to trump is soft on white
supremacism you have to say number one
the proud boys are a white supremacist
group and two trump was taking
leadership of them and telling them to
arm up which he was not doing
which he was not doing in fact that what
are the chances that trump actually
knows who the proud boys are like really
knows who they are
trump does this crap all the time
because he has never not sounded off on
an issue
right he says who are you talking about
it's joe biden who inserts the proud
boys into that conversation
trump yesterday was asked about the
proud boys and trump was like i don't
even know who they are
you mentioned a name you threw it out
there i was like okay so stand back and
stand down or stand by or whatever it is
here was trump yesterday i don't know
who the proud boys are i mean you have
to give me a definition because i really
don't know who they are
i can only say they have to stand down
let law enforcement do their work
law enforcement will do the work more
and more as people see how bad this
radical liberal democrat movement is and
how weak
the law enforcement's going to come back
stronger and stronger
but again i don't know who proud boys
are but whoever they are they have to
stand down
let law enforcement do their work okay
this is a completely manufactured media
narrative this one
it really is there are times when trump
has said things and it is not a
manufactured media narrative
this one is manufactured out of whole
cloth you can watch the clip yourself
you can analyze it yourself
unless you go in with the predicate that
donald trump is a white supremacist you
cannot read that
as a white supremacist statement nor any
of the statements to follow you know
white supremacists generally don't do
the following day
again say for the thousandth time they
can then white supremacy and also
that the proud boys should stand down
that's the thing they don't do
i mean it's amazing the media conflate
every single person
they don't agree with with white
supremacy and then say that if you
condemn those people or if you tell them
to stand down you're a defender of white
supremacy
again go back and listen when i think
that trump has said things that are soft
on white supremacy i've blasted the
living crap out of him
probably more than anybody on the right
actually i won't say probably
certainly more than anybody on the right
that is not what happened at the debate
last night and the attempt to
manufacture this narrative in advance of
the election
is really a media creation and quite a
disgusting media creation
at that and you can see by the way the
media
spinning this narrative up in real time
on everything
you wonder why there's such a level of
distrust in the country on these sorts
of issues on racial issues
maybe it has something to do with the
media that will somehow come up with the
idea that this was a soft on white
supremacy moment for trump in the debate
and at the same exact time they will
throw out there that kyle rittenhouse is
a white supremacist i mean
remembers the media who are saying this
at the time in kenosha
in a second i'm going to get to a piece
from nbc news that is truly incredible
in terms of his bias against
kyle rittenhouse and against the trump
administration we'll get to that in just
one second first
let us talk about something great that
you can do for your parents okay
something great you can do for yourself
that is you can preserve all of those
family memories so out in the garage you
got a bunch of old pictures you got old
film reels you've got
vhs tapes that you're never going to
look at again you know what you should
do with all that stuff you should get it
translated over to a digital format but
how can you accomplish this incredible
thing all you have to do is head on over
to legacy box
legacy box is an ingenious mail and
service to have all those irreplaceable
moments trapped on videotapes camcorders
tapes
film reels pictures convert it to dvd or
digital
one song one photo one sniff of
nostalgia can take you back to the past
but with all that stuff molding in the
garage you can't do anything this is why
you need legacy box it's a way for you
to easily and affordably digitally
preserve your past the process from
start to finish is incredibly easy you
pack and you send their team digitizes
everything by hand and then you enjoy
get back perfectly preserved digital
copies on thumb drive dvd or the cloud
ready to watch
share and enjoy they've thought of
everything they even provide
state-of-the-art tracking and send you
updates at every step of the process
send your precious recorded moments to a
company you can trust it was founded by
college roommates nick and adam over a
decade ago i know them they are great
dudes you can certainly trust them with
your family memories get started
preserving your past
today go to legacybox.com to get an
incredible 40
off your first order i've done this for
my own parents it's great
buy today take advantage of this
exclusive offer send in when you are
ready go to legacybox.com
shapiro save 40 while supplies last
okay in just a second we'll get to more
of this make sure to go over to daily
wire and subscribe so you can get behind
that pay while you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so you want to know why trump is so
skeptical of the media
whenever they say we want you to condemn
x group or y group because
he literally doesn't know whether they
are asking him to condemn a white
supremacist group or whether they are
asking him to become a not white
supremacist group
the reason that he doesn't know that is
because the media are dishonest about
this sort of stuff
they are they will just lump everybody
together they will say that everybody
they don't like is a white supremacist
and that that by the way is in fact the
the anti-racist theory that the media
have been pushing
the media have been pushing the theory
that if you are white you are by nature
a white supremacist because you engage
in a system of white supremacy
gavin newsom the garbage governor of
california state i'm about to leave
he tweeted out yesterday that california
just became the first state in the
nation
to mandate the study and development of
proposals for reparations
our past he says is one of slavery
racism and injustice our systems were
built to oppress
people of color our systems are not
built to oppress people of color but if
you believe that and then if you believe
that you're quote-unquote complicit in
those systems you are a white
supremacist by nature the same
media who are on the side of people like
gavin newsom these same people
this is a crazy story nbc news printed
an article today called internal
document shows trump officials were told
to make comments sympathetic to kyle
britton house
so what you would think is that they
were told to lie to make comments
sympathetic to kyle written house
no they weren't they were told to say
accurate things about kyle rittenhouse
and nbc news
found this worthy of reporting on
according to nbc news federal law
enforcement officials were directed to
make public comments sympathetic to kyle
rittenhouse the teenager charged with
fatally shooting two protesters in
kenosha
according to internal dhs talking points
obtained by nbc news
the document suggests that the dhs note
that he
took his rifle to the scene of the
rioting to help defend small business
owners he is on tape
saying exactly that that is not biasing
the case
with regard to kyle written house that
is a documented fact
another set of talking points
distributed to homeland security
officials said the media were
incorrectly
labeling the group patriot pair as
racist after clashes erupted between the
group and protesters in portland oregon
again that happens to be a fact
patriot prayer is not a white
supremacist group the media were falsely
labeling them a white supremacist group
to say that white supremacists had
caused the violence in portland
the media think that this is bad the
media shouldn't be fact checked on their
attempt to smear everybody
to the right of hillary clinton as a
racist so
that that conversation is so fraught
that trump is i think rightly skeptical
of the media's take on what constitutes
racism and what does not constitute
racism
but putting that to one side the the
entire narrative here which is that the
takeaway from the debate is that trump
would soft on white supremacy again
if he had been i would blast him i have
done so in the past
the reason people are very angry with me
today is because i'm using my best
judgment to determine that in that quote
he is not doing that
okay now there's another narrative that
the media are trying to draw out
from the debate the other night and that
is all of the election
fallout so they are suggesting that
trump is a threat to the election
now again this is a media creation into
which trump absolutely stops
so for months we have heard from months
years we have heard from democrats that
donald trump
is not a duly elected president that he
was in fact put in place by the russians
as it turns out that is not true and
then we have heard that republicans have
biased
every major election right george w bush
was not legitimately elected donald
trump was not legitimately elected
stacy abrams is the actual governor of
georgia
voter fraud is rampant in republican
states republicans attempt to suppress
the vote
this is a generic democratic talking
point at this point
there have been full articles written
about john podesta prepping
for the possibility of insane
post-election
maneuvering should donald trump win
victory
we know that the biden team has hired
hundreds of lawyers in preparation for
exactly that
there's a weird twenty 000 word piece in
the atlantic
positing all these bizarre scenarios
whereby donald trump was going to hole
up in the white house like
like al pacino at the end of scarface
snorting coke and firing guns
to prevent being dragged out of the oval
office even after losing an election
legitimately so this is left wing wish
casting
if donald trump loses the election he
will go now donald trump made a boo-boo
in the last debate because he decided to
play right into all of that so donald
trump plays the same game as left this
is
this is the the deep truth of donald
trump he is a fun house mirror for the
left everything the left does
donald trump does except a little bit
more so if you get chris cuomo doing the
cable news routine you get donald trump
doing the cable news routine except more
if the left suggests that election fraud
is going to skew the election such that
republicans are going to win
you'll get donald trump saying exactly
the same thing back to them you guys are
going to skew the election results so
that you guys win
and then that plays into the left-wing
narrative so this has been the left-wing
narrative for the last couple of days
because donald trump when asked about
the election
said there's the possibility for serious
election fraud there's the serious
possibility
of voter fraud and votes not being
counted and it could be a mess
now the real answer to that is a duly
certified election is one that i will
respect
if we have evidence of malfeasance then
that is something that we will have to
deal with when it comes up
that's the actual answer that's always
the answer but because trump is trump he
immediately went to
well you know we'll have to see and then
and when we see maybe we won't maybe we
will
okay so now the media have spun up this
entire narrative
as an attack on voting and so there
there's a huge article in the new york
times about how trump
is depressing the vote right they
literally say that trump is undermining
the election by claiming voter fraud
so i have a question they're saying that
donald trump is a threat to the
legitimacy of the elections
but also he is a threat to the he is a
threat to the election
because he himself is responsible for
voter fraud
so either he likes the voter fraud or he
doesn't like the voter fraud but
apparently he likes both right no matter
what how the election goes
donald trump will be responsible so if
donald trump wins it'll be due to voter
fraud also if donald trump loses and
then claims voter fraud it's because
he's bad
right this is the way that the media are
playing his comments the other night
that doesn't mean that trump has handled
that issue properly i criticized him
yesterday on the show for handling the
issue that way but this is the narrative
that democrats
are drawing because it's a heads i win
tails you lose scenario again
if donald trump wins it's because of
voter fraud there's an attack
on trump in the new york times called
the attack on voting with just a bunch
of and basically the entire story is
just a bunch of tweets
from trump about how there are various
forms of voting that are a problem
now all those headlines about voter
fraud amplified daily on facebook and
twitter served a purpose as the new york
times they laid the groundwork for a
legal challenge the trump campaign had a
team of election lawyers standing by to
dispute election results
throughout the country and republican
national lawyers association had ready
to self-described
navy seal type operation to fight
similar cases in the event of a
republican loss they would need a story
and fraud it was the truth appeared to
be a secondary concern
at best there's only one problem with
this which is of course democrats have
also hired the exact same number of
people
as of the 2020 presidential election
years as the new york times it is
becoming clear the trump administration
and the republican party are not just
looking at but heavily investing in the
largely non-existent problem
of voter fraud a new york times magazine
investigation based on a review of
thousands of pages of court records and
interviews with more than 100 key
players found an extensive effort to
gain partisan advantage
by aggressively promoting the false
claim that voter fraud is a pervasive
problem
the story did not originate with trump
and then of course they suggest that
this is all about
um racism of course of course it's not
that trump is trying to suppress votes
that of people who don't vote for him
it's that he's a racist
voter fraud is an adaptable fiction says
the new york times and the president has
tailored it to the moment
so what instead you have from the left
is voter suppression if trump loses
then it's because he lost legitimately
but if he wins it's because of voter
suppression
if he wins it's because he said voter
fraud and that created voter suppression
which again is a myth there is no voter
suppression in the united states nobody
is blocking anybody from voting
so again another media crafted narrative
into which trump falls head first
because this is the way our stupid
politics work and by the way
if you think that it's getting better
after if trump loses it's not getting
better
it's just that all of this will be
weaponized on behalf of biden the same
way that it was weaponized on behalf of
barack obama and enemies of the biden
administration
will become enemies of the press okay
meanwhile
speaking of the militarization of
certain aspects of our government
james comey went to the hill yesterday
so as it turns out
there have been a variety of stories
that have arisen over the past several
years
demonstrating that the fbi investigation
into the trump campaign
was falsely premised that the steele
dossier which was the center of the
thing
was basically russian disinformation and
that people knew by the end of 2016 was
russian disinformation they continued to
promulgate it as the basis for fisa
warrants
so james comey who presided over the fbi
during this entire period
and is going to go down in history as
maybe the worst fbi director
ever i mean really truly an awful fbi
director
so james comey testified on the hill and
he testified in the aftermath
of a bombshell allegation andy mccarthy
reporting for
national review hillary clinton
personally signed off on the russiagate
farce to distract attention from her
email scandal according to a russian
intelligence analysis
obtained by u.s intelligence agencies in
july 2016. that is the bombshell
allegation
national intelligence director john
ratcliffe has just dropped on the senate
judiciary committee with the first
presidential debate just a few hours
away
and with former fbi director james comey
scheduled to testify before that
committee
tomorrow morning ratliff's ratcliffe's
letter to committee chairman lindsey
graham asserts that in late july 2016
american intelligence agencies obtained
insight into an analysis
by russian spies which alleged that
democratic us presidential candidate
hillary clinton had approved a plan to
stir up a scandal against a republican
opponent donald trump
the plan involved tying trump to putin
and the russians hacking of the dnc
let's put this information in context
clinton
was cleared of criminal charges in a
july 5th 2016 presser
by comey this prompted outrage over
whether the obama administration had
distorted the criminal law
applicable to mishandling classified
information to give clinton a pass
the email scandal with dog clinton
throughout the campaign on july 25th
less than three weeks after the comey
press conference the 2016 dnc convention
began in philadelphia
three days earlier july 22nd the hacked
dnc emails began
to be published by that point former
british spy christopher steele had been
commissioned by the clinton campaign to
compile research tying trump to russia
steele ran a london-based private
intelligence business whose clients
include russian oligarchs moreover in
compiling the dossier steele relied
heavily on igor danchenko a man the fbi
investigated in 2009 2010
on suspicion he was a russian spy days
after the hack dnc emails began being
published steel generated a dossier
report
alleging that trump was in a
well-developed conspiracy of cooperation
with russian leadership
the evidence of extensive conspiracy
between trump's campaign team and the
kremlin
steele claimed included the hacking and
publication of dnc emails
quote the russian regime had been behind
the recent leak of embarrassing email
messages emanating from the dnc's
wikileaks the operation said steele had
the full knowledge and support of trump
and senior members
of the team in exchange trump had
purportedly committed to both downplay
russian intervention in ukraine and
raise american defense commitments to
nato as campaign issues
further steele claimed that trump had
quote moles within the dnc and hackers
in the us as well as outside in russia
on the trump side steele said the
conspiracy was managed by paul manafort
was purportedly using carter page as an
intermediary
the story was absurd through and through
as mccarthy says
clinton is not a correspondent in the
dnc emails and was not harmed by them
plainly it would have been easy for
steele to weave this tale together from
public reporting
page and manafort didn't know each other
in the same dossier report steel claimed
russia was using its consulate in miami
as a hub for the arrangement with trump
russia didn't have a consulate
in miami radcliffe's letter concedes the
us intelligence community does not know
the accuracy of the allegation that
hillary
personally orchestrated the collusion
scandal nor can our agencies say whether
russian intelligence analysis is
disinformation
nevertheless the allegation about
clinton's role was known to the obama
administration
at the time ratcliffe elaborates that
handwritten notes from
former cia director john brennan show
brennan briefed obama and other senior
national security officials
about the intelligence including the
quote alleged approval by hillary
clinton on july 26 2016
of a proposal from one for foreign
policy advisors to vilify donald trump
by stirring up a scandal claiming
interference by russian security
services
apparently in early september u.s intel
officials forwarded to fbi director
comey
and agent peter strzok an investigative
referral regarding quote u.s
presidential candidate hillary clinton's
approval of a plan
concerning u.s presidential candidate
donald trump and russian hackers
hampering u.s elections as a means of
distracting the public from her use
of a private email server director
radcliffe closes his letter by
explaining there is other related
intelligence that remains classified
apparently
that intelligence will not be
declassified it turns out that ci
director gina haspel
according to sean davis over at the
federalist is blocking release of
further russia gate documents
okay so now we have a russian
intelligence document which itself could
be disinformation
claiming that hillary clinton basically
concocted the whole russiagate scandal
in order to
distract from email gate is that true
is that not we have no idea but we
certainly know that the russian
dossier the steele dossier was russian
disinformation so we know that much
do we know that this was russian infra
we have no idea one thing we do know the
fbi
botched this thing from beginning to end
so james comey the self-righteous former
fbi director he appears in front of
congress yesterday
and he proceeds to spout a bunch of
conspiracy theories so for example he
was asked about trump's finances and he
just speculates that trump's finances
make him susceptible to blackmail again
this is the guy
who is tasked with leading he was with
the leader the leading
law enforcement agency of the united
states the fbi he was tasked with
heading that
and he's just out there engaging in
ranked speculation this doofus was
running the entire operation
mr comey is personal debt an important
consideration
when an individual is seeking a security
clearance
yes why because a person's financial
situation
could make them vulnerable to coercion
by an adversary
and allow an adversary to do what we try
to do to foreign government officials we
find are indebted and that is recruit
them to our side
so go ahead i'm sorry so it's a serious
issue in any background review
so someone with substantial personal
debt may be vulnerable to influence by a
foreign adversary
yes a government official okay so
this is the the again the democrats
trying to concoct
various conspiracy theories about trump
now those conspiracy theories about
trump were used to target
the trump campaign they were used to
target carter page falsely now
hilariously james comey then testified
in front of congress
that everything in russiagate was done
by the book which is patently intro i
mean it's clearly clearly untrue here's
lindsey graham asking him about it
how would you rank rate the crossfire
hurricane investigation in terms of
being done
thoroughly by the book an investigation
the fbi should be proud of
i i'm not sure i can apply a number
scale but i would say in the main it was
done
by the book it was appropriate and it
was essential that it be done
okay so you're proud of it
overall i'm proud of the work there are
parts of it that are concerning which
i'm sure we'll talk about but overall
i'm proud of the work
proud of the work okay so what exactly
did james comey know about the work
as it turns out he knew nothing about
the work so he was asked over and over
again
about the investigation and he just said
i can't recall i don't know i don't know
i can't recall but i'm very proud of it
i don't remember that's about all i
recall i don't remember
i don't remember learning anything
additional about steel's sources
not that i recall no i don't remember or
ever
giving i don't recall that so do you
recall
i do not do you recall i do not i don't
remember any discussion
i don't remember using that word but i
don't remember using that word i don't
remember
ever being informed i don't recall being
informed of that did you ask any
questions or do any due diligence on
this at all
i don't remember anything about the the
facts that have been revealed recently
about the subsource
okay so but he's very proud of the work
that was the guy who was trusted to lead
up this
operation i mean comey himself said by
the way that there's this faiza
application taken out against carter
page it was based on that steele dossier
it was predicated entirely on crap
okay and they knew it was crap
apparently when they took out the
renewals of the fisa warrant
lindsey graham asked comey about it he
was like well you know even though i
personally signed the documentation it's
not my job to make sure the fisa
applications are accurate
oh is that how that works whose job
is it to make sure the facts are right
when you present them to the
fisa court well the most basic level the
affiant
whoever is signing the affidavit did you
sign the affidavit
no i signed a certification which is
required of the fbi director
okay does the fbi director have any
responsibility to make sure the facts
are right when they're given to the
court not in connection with the
certification but in general the fbi
director is responsible for everything
that's being done underneath the fbi
director
oh but but he's not responsible for
anything because it's not his job it's
not his job
ted cruz concluded this line of
questioning by basically slapping comey
around he says that you know
at this point i don't know what to tell
is this just incompetence or deliberate
corruption like what the hell happened
here
this investigation of the president was
corrupt the fbi and the department of
justice were politicized and weaponized
and in my opinion there are only two
possibilities
that you were deliberately corrupt or
woefully incompetent
and i don't believe you were incompetent
this has done severe damage to the
professionals and the honorable men and
women at the fbi
because law enforcement should not be
used as a political weapon
and that is the legacy you've left
so how easy is it you know people say
how easy is it for the media to concoct
various narratives about political
figures the answer is very very easy for
three
long years and now into the fourth year
we've been told that donald trump was a
cat's paw of the russians and now the
media have concocted other narratives
and their narratives include that donald
trump is going to steal the election
somehow he has not
they've concocted the narrative that
republicans are routinely engaged in
voter suppression they have not
they've concocted the narrative that
that debate the other night was all
about trump going soft on white
supremacy
it was not in the end will there be a
comeuppance for the media i think the
comeuppance is already happening
and that people are tuning out they are
tuning out from the media and you know
when that's really going to become
apparent
when donald trump is not president the
sad irony of all of this for the media
is that their greatest wish which is to
throw trump out of office on his ear
their greatest wish which is to take
trump down and replace him with again
the next step
in the leftist revolution via elderly
joe biden and his
potemkin village of an administration
the
the goal is going to result in their
utter destruction
why because it turns out that they feed
they prey
on donald trump right they feed on him
trump feeds into it obviously but they
they need donald trump it is a symbiotic
relationship they require donald trump
in order to get the ratings
that generate all of the money that they
use to push forward
the the agenda that they want
and what happens when they are deprived
of that well then it turns out more and
more people are going to recognize them
for the propaganda outlet they are
and people are going to start ignoring
the media again and you're going to see
an uptick in the number of people who
are going to alternative media sources
and frankly i think that'll be great for
the country okay we'll back here later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
trump refuses to condemn white
supremacists except for all the times
he's condemned white supremacists
a leftist tv host calls presidential
debates quote a threat to black life
and a professor is forced to apologize
for liking college football
check it out on the michael knowles show